the first chance we had to work on a
project that was really so profound for
organization was with the black-footed
ferret we got a call from fish and
wildlife and we heard the story of the
black-footed ferret
it used to range across the Great Plains
from Mexico to Canada
and that was until in the 1800s this
land actually became agricultural fields
and the black-footed ferrets and their
primary source of prey which is the
prairie dog
were all literally exterminated and by
1981 they were none
until one small population was found in
matitsi Wyoming
Wyoming Game and Fish brought that small
population into captivity bred them over
time and very successfully have
reintroduced them to over 30 sites back
into their original range
however over 30 years all 10 500 ferrets
have been bred in captivity from just a
Founder gene pool of seven ferrets that
had been wild caught now everybody knows
that inbreeding is not a great thing and
when species
get into smaller and smaller populations
they run the risk of going down the
extinction Vortex when smaller
populations cause greater
genetic drift lower fertility counts and
even become more susceptible to Wildlife
diseases increasing their mortality
now when we got the call from Fish and
Wildlife to ask if we could help the
first thing we said was there any other
population that you can bring in to
restore genetic diversity because that's
the typical tool in technology bring in
a population from another area and
increase fertility lower the mortality
rate increase the population and becomes
more stable
but there was no other population for
the black-footed ferret
so we heard that within the San Diego
frozen Zoo Back 40 years ago somebody
was prescient enough to actually Bank
cell lines from two other individuals
that had been wild caught in 1981 but
had never contributed to the gene pool
with that we did the genomic sequencing
on those two cell lines and we found
that They Carried up to three times more
genetic diversity than any living ferret
so if we could actually clone those
ferrets we could start to build up that
population not by moving animals but by
moving genes by partnering with the San
Diego Zoo and a partner viogen as a
cloning company and with U.S fish and
wildlife under their permit
in 2020 we cloned Elizabeth Anne she's
the first
she's the first endangered species in
America to ever be cloned
now this is an amazing success story and
and it was a first for conservation to
actually use these Technologies in this
way but to me what's actually almost
more amazing is the fact that scientists
back in 1980s were precedent enough to
start to think about cryopreservation
now cloning didn't exist then at all
they didn't know what they were going to
do with these cells
and that got us thinking what else has
been ever cryo preserved
it turns out that less than 14 percent
of U.S endangered species have any form
of cryopreservation that includes plants
and animals out of the 1500 that's an
alarming low number and it's a
particularly alarming low number when
you realize the rate of Extinction loss
just in the last hundred years and the
trend keeps going up
so with that we started talking with
officials at Fish and Wildlife service
and we suggested to them that if we
could figure out why this isn't
happening that we could actually help
create protocols and a and actually a
road map to help ensure that every
species
that is endangered in the U.S and the
Fish and Wildlife service has a
responsibility to actually get them back
off the list
we've said why don't they just include
in that whole process taking a cell
culture and ensuring that they that
species has a reference genome that can
be open access and used by researchers
all over the world
so with this idea we're trying to
actually Bank species for the present to
help make better management decisions
based on their DNA but the truth is
they're really going to be put in the
bank to also help future generations
with unknown technologies that are
Unthinkable today but could be
transformative in the future
and here's our partner Seth Willey this
is actually the same guy who called us
to ask could we help him with the
black-footed ferret Ten Years Later Seth
is a major partner in this whole
initiative
you know we're responsible in the
southwest region there's about 200
threatened endangered species Nationwide
responsible for about 1500 threatened
endangered species and it got me
wondering you know are we doing our part
to set up future Generations the same
way somebody set up Blackford Affair for
that success 30 years before by
biobanking by cryogenically preserving
that specimen that sample and the answer
we came to was
Hit or Miss I mean we're doing it in
Little Bits here and there you know in
conservation if one of the first
premises says save what you have
this is one tool that gives us that
option to save what we have not for
academic purposes but for recovery for
genetic rescue and push species back to
the point of being biologically viable
in this game in conservation dangerous
species recovery we're entrusted to
protect some of the nation's most
valuable and unique biological resources
that conservation Legacy is entrusted to
us and we're responsible for trying to
arrest a species decline to manage
threats and to bring species back from
the brink
genetic diversity took millions of years
to evolve and
you know we're losing it on our watch
but it's not too late right there's
still great opportunity for those
Critters and for many others it's our
responsibility to try to do what we can
to save what's there today
so that's what we're doing we've started
this pilot with our first species that's
the Mexican wolf it is native to New
Mexico and Arizona there are only 200
left in the wild today and on a routine
vet check last month the fueled
biologist team working with revive and
restore actually was able to sample that
Mexican wolf
send off the sample to our culturing
partner with viogen and it's now on its
way for sequencing and we'll be going
for long-term storage at a federal
facility so one down we've got another
1500 to do